so once again here's a theory I'd like
to share with you I got more of them
than killmead's got hair plugs
totally totally unnecessary it was
unnecessary we're starting early thank
you but I want to talk about how
performance has replaced belief from
politics to the classroom to social
media let's start with the Democrats
newest Star Justin Pearson he's one of
the Tennessee Dems who started a near
riot in a government building and
disrupted a legislative session with a
bullhorn but to understand how he's now
a star let's go back a bit here he is in
2016 while in college
I'm Justin J Pearson and I'm running for
president of BSG there are a few reasons
that we're running this campaign this
year one has to do with representation
how can we represent all voices in a
conversation I want to do this by
partnering with organizations from the
Boon Democrats to the Buddha Republicans
I want to bring together different
voices dissenting voices voices that may
be more liberal or more conservative in
order that we can reach a point of sort
of the radical middle oh my God he seems
like the nicest young man ever running
for school office and he makes so much
sense
there he is now
seem like the NRA in gun lobbyists might
win
but oh that was good news for us I don't
know how long this Saturday in the state
of Tennessee might last but oh we have
good news folks we've got good news that
Sunday always comes
amazing Malcolm in the Middle became
Malcolm X in the middle
transition like this since this guy
became this girl
That's Not Right
But since Pearson led a Revolt in a
government building he's now a liberal
darling if Republicans did that they'd
be in jail well unless they're FBI
informants but instead of getting shot
or put in solitary Democrats get
worshiped like me when I do yoga at the
local nude beach
but it's such a transformation for
Pearson it makes you wonder how
authentic is it it's happened before
let's go to the first tape clearance
they threaten we recognize Taiwan as
legitimate China until the 1970s then
that flips we say okay but just
recognize taiwanzo autonomy they go
that's fine
all right well let's see it a month
later
[Music]
[Applause]
Saturday in the state of Tennessee my
last but oh we have good news folks
we've got good news that someday always
comes
you know I would call that a distinct
Improvement I got I I went with the
moment yes you did like that somehow I
needed to change but you see how
contagious artificial emotion can be
it's the source code of the new woke
where the performance matters and
nothing else it's happening more because
we incentivize it I mean why do men
suddenly decide that they're women
they've been incentivized suddenly the
non-binary male is on par with the
actual female in the area of Rights
that's a first now in articles decrying
sexual discrimination females and trans
females are grouped together even if
they're still biological men not bad
right you still get to have a penis but
also become a protected class and wear
pumps
our old friend Kayla lamoux totally got
it the Canadian teacher with fake
breasts the size of a dairy farm
he decided to exploit the exploit the
identity politics Griff to the point of
absurdity here's new video from this
week again he's back to his normal self
were real
where are your breasts
why are you dressing inappropriately in
front of children but did you notice no
brass but Lemieux I thought you told the
world via the New York Post and the
Toronto Sun that those were real mammary
glands
it's true Kayla had said those breasts
magically grew organically he said it
was a symptom of gigantism but now
they're gone now did they shrink in the
cold
it happens
trust me
but now everyone's a performance artist
with beliefs as fluid as deer piss
and speaking of deer piss
you see that sales of Bud Light
are literally
they're literally in tan
thanks to partnering with Dylan Mulvaney
the performance artist who like the
Canadian teacher indulged stereotypes of
women and drove beer sales into the
toilet one bar owner in St Louis where
bud is headquartered says sales of Bud
drop 50 over the past week another in
New York City said Bud Light bottle
sales were down 70 percent and a bar in
Texas that usually sells three kegs of
Bud Light a week sold four bottles the
big picture according to the New York
Post Anheuser-Busch lost more than five
billion dollars in value during this
controversy
and why because consumers are keenly
aware of in inauthenticity it's as phony
as Jesse's last rap album
yeasty boy
and the reaction to all this is healthy
because you know this isn't a left-wing
boycott it's just consumers registering
their exhaustion with force-fed virtue
signaling nonsense they're sick of the
performances of course Justin Pearson
isn't the first politician to fake it
remember this
I'm proud to be a bartender
[Music]
there's nothing wrong with working
retail folding clothes for other people
to buy
there's nothing wrong with preparing the
food that your neighbors will eat
and I get a witness up in here and
let's not forget the original
I don't feel no Ways Tired
come too far
from where I started from nobody told me
that the road would be easy
I don't believe he brought me this far
to leave me whatever you say Wheezy
Jefferson
my favorite Jefferson
but sometimes politicians do get caught
yeah
Sacagawea more like
and it's not just politicians remember
Alec Baldwin's wife
have very few ingredients we have
tomatoes we have um
cucumber cucumbers that never gets old
how you say cucumber I want that on my
tombstone in fact as cucumbers are
really an underrated medical device
what
that's what we're asking yes
[Applause]
Pierce I got to get Pearson Credit in an
era of wokeism we're pretending to be
aggrieved is required Pierce and dove in
head first to get ahead play the victim
game the system but like someone famous
once said don't hate the player hate the
game you know I believe it was this guy
[Applause]
started that perfect gag dance because
they make readers throw up co-host of
fox and friends Brian kill me foreign
ER kellyanne Conway
she's like a Q-tip skinny white and
damaging to your ears Fox News
contributor captive
and a family of bald eagles has a nest
behind his left ear my massive sidekick
and the NWA World Heavyweight Champion
Tyrus
all right
Tyrus I knew it
okay two-part question which Pearson was
the real Pearson and would he be a good
wrestler
um no because he's phony people it was
fake yeah and as I stand here today I
tell you
look I'm I'm all good with changing
views I changed views but I didn't
change my clothes with my views
you know I'm saying I was dressed this
way when I was thinking you know what
I'm a Democrat
the man you know and then I got my
paycheck
and my taxes got taken out I was like I
need to learn about the man because
this taxation stuff is terrible yeah but
I didn't turn my hat around yeah I
didn't get a suit I didn't start talking
like I sit uptight all day like good
evening everyone I'm so happy you were
here I didn't you know oh my gosh golly
yeah I didn't change who I am to have a
point of view change so neither one of
those are him yeah he's just whatever
we'll get him in the door right and
that's a problem because there's no
difference than him than Devin or any of
the other performance artists they will
do anything to get on TV the cold part
is apparently and this is one thing
we're learning there's just one acting
coach for all of them obviously Hillary
was the one who needed the most help but
it's all the same thing
it's the old school guy probably from
somewhere in Detroit an out of work
Reverend with some sketchy backside who
talks like this and yeah and you got to
do this and speak from here and that way
rhyme when you talk what kind of rhyme
when you don't and people you'll sound
just like the king and it doesn't matter
what you're saying and the worst was AOC
basically said she folded clothes
and worked as a waitress in the spirit
of Martin Luther King
I have a dream he did too and that
wasn't it yes so
[Applause]
Ryan what's strange about you is that
everybody wishes you wouldn't be
yourself right that's interesting did
you take notes on my background by the
way worst intro ever I've been into it
on Martha Martha McCallum had me on at
three o'clock today beautiful intro
talked about my shows and my impact on
society and what did you basically say
my books are gag gifts yes because they
make people throw up right I need a
crisis manager after doing this show
this reminded me of Colin Kaepernick
Colin Kaepernick's a Super Bowl
quarterback a player two away from being
a Super Bowl champion and he had the
most promising future and one thing led
to another he stopped being productive
he gets bench next thing you know
they're saying he's sitting during the
national anthem then he's kneeling
during the national anthem then he grows
his hair out changes his clothes
realizes he's bigger than football sues
the NFL and no one realized he just
forgot how to play football good and
that's why he changed and now he's
somebody he's not which is why he
doesn't give any interviews he never
talks Muhammad Ali was a revolutionary
but he wanted the interview he wanted to
change the dialogue it's going to be
very interesting to see if this guy can
hold up and actually to put up with an
interview a cross-examination about what
he stands for because the Democrats are
putting a whole bunch of money in time
behind him right now yeah you know
kellyanne it seems to me that wokeism is
like the old is basically only about
performance right I mean I can't believe
that the people that get mad at anybody
like us actually feels that way because
we're doing nothing like if they get mad
they get angry they yell it they yell at
Riley Gaines as she starts it's like
it's all a performance it is and people
are famous for being famous now remember
Michael avenatti now serving multiple
decades yes for a criminal sentences
well
um
Greg's favorite
um commentator Brian stelter told
Michael avenatti I think you could be
president if you're such a good
communicator but he became famous for
being famous and one TV show leads to
the next leads to the next and in the
end he went to jail for extorting Nike
he went to jail for stealing money from
clients including a quadriplegic client
but I think that instead of learning the
lesson of Hillary Clinton and avoiding
all things Hillary especially when it
comes to phony campaigning and
authenticity Jill Biden Joe Biden Kamala
Harris the whole a lot of them have
learned from her do you remember Jill
Biden went to California and she flubbed
a
feet she was given to Hispanic group she
tried uh it was about breakfast no that
was Texas oh yeah I was getting to that
then she compared them to breakfast
tacos Kamala Harris went to Paris and
she faked this French accent people to
judge I mean just his qualifications to
be Secretary of Transportation itself
for a joke you made an important word at
the beginning it's incentivized but
people cut through it it starts in
Washington honestly in Hollywood Kat are
you still mad that you aren't the
spokesperson for Bud Light
yes yes I mean you should be I just
think it would make more sense it would
I would buy that beer I would too who
has a broyer Vibe than I did no you call
him crispy boys crispy boy crispy it's
boy you get it yes uh okay so so much of
our discourse is performative because of
social media and I write about this in
my book which is out in six days and all
the people I know
I know all the free people who
pre-ordered it are going to be so happy
and all the ones who didn't are going to
be so upset that they don't want
everyone's talking about they're gonna
be crying they're gonna be throwing up
it's gonna be horrible for those people
um but unlike in real life social media
actually rewards outrage there's been
research done on this that these moral
emotional or grandstanding language
makes posts more popular on Twitter or
on Facebook and you think about how
different that is from real life if
there was someone you knew in real life
who was just constantly just making
these grandiose moral emotional
statements with all these loaded words
you would stop inviting that person to
brunch like that's but it's rewarded on
social media because everyone wants to
be popular on social media because you
want to feel like do you want everyone
else to see how much everyone else likes
you yeah so it's destroying the
discourse which should be reflective of
reality which is issues are complex and
so are human beings excellent all right
we gotta move on up next robots that
fight crime the taxpayers dime hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else